ah
[Music]
uh shout out to jim shock by the way
great guys
wearing i love this color on me by the
way has anyone noticed that
that's the one that you've got the photo
taken yeah like you look it makes you
look
jacked jacked and shouted
thank you very much also to jim sharp
for sorting out myself and my wife uh
she's very happy with the clothing that
you provide
and i am also thrilled with the clothing
that you provided for my wife
thank you very much daughter man as
would say not dirty dirty daughty
bastard no no i don't know where that
one um you know what i will uh first
podcast back in a while shout out to all
the long-term loyal subscribers we're
bringing it back we are actually
bringing it back gymshark by the way
yeah putting us through a photo shoot do
you know that i see it putting me
through a photo shoot i mean it that way
is it that like espn naked thing where
you're going to stand on camera and go
it's definitely not okay
i actually think you'd be great for that
put it this way i'm already nervous
about getting photographed with clothes
on
right because that wasn't what you said
the other night when you sent me that
picture you said is this rash going to
clear up and i went oh seriously [__]
off um seriously though why why is
someone taking photos of you without me
around so just exactly just to be clear
i think i might ask you to come actually
um when is it around i don't know um but
the point is is i'm not used to like not
having control at this point
like everything we shoot every photo we
take i get the okay before it goes out
and everyone has angles of themselves
that they don't like
and especially a 21 stone man like you
know some angles you look buff you look
like you know jacked and tanned yeah and
then some angles
right yeah festively plump chubby
fanster true geordie takes photos i mean
bmi wise i'm obese let's be real so
bmi and
it's it is concerning so i was on the
phone uh our good buddy at gymshark
george shout out to him love that he's
such a great guy yeah we become pulse
and um he he was like oh it's gonna be
fine these are experts and but in my
head i'm like
i work with experts every day and [__]
goes wrong that's so true as well
every single day this guy's always
[__] up no but
but i'm the type of person i feel like i
catch mistakes like 12 13 times a day
like like [__] covert yeah yeah and
and so i i can't relax like that you
know what i mean and also it's like wait
there right if you look on gymshark
socials
those beautiful beautiful people
look nothing like me yeah so yes they
make those [__] look wonderful yeah
this [__] yeah good luck to you it's
when you walk in the room and they go
you didn't say we were gonna have to
well for a start it's an hour for hair
and makeup i'm like well i mean
why an hour why an hour you said you'd
make me laugh this is funny no but why
are you taking a photo for gymshark uh
it's it's for the new rate the power
range remember the power rangers the
only one that really you when it arrived
you went that is that was that's a
little bit of me so it was very me and i
wore it to death and it it to be fair i
think that that's why they wanted me and
the next version of it is like they're
like it's kind of your thing now at this
point however lately they've been
bringing a lot more stuff that does fit
me and i actually have been well as you
can tell rather rather happy with it
shout out to them but i am i am a little
nervous because he was like oh they've
got a massive crew everything will be
fine i'm like right that's even better
now for hair and makeup right got near
here yeah and this is the space left
from for my face for the maker oh no
your fingers aren't reaching all the way
up the forehead but there is the the but
what i'm saying is the beard down here
does take a while to sort of she's gonna
and imagine it's awesome
she might just sort of bring a little
comb in here and just sort of angular
you know
i can do my own beard i don't need
anyone
um and they sent me a load of exercises
that they're going to film me doing
shoot and i'm like i've been boxing i've
been dead lifting for a while [__] are
they are they be dead lift are they
gonna be real weights or is it gonna be
one of those things
i mean i'd hope it would be plastic with
it's given um what some of those lads do
well i know what bumstead really does
when he's having him i've i've seen him
do it oh i'm just yeah lifting some real
weights that's a huge bodybuilder
sponsor for those wondering what
bumstead means yeah um
really uh very handsome guy yeah he
looks like a chiseled adonis honestly
i've never felt more inferior than when
i looked at his photographs i'm like
what the [__] am i
what's the point why am i doing a photo
shoot what have i got this guy you've
got him just use him for everything he's
great right don't worry about it yeah
what are you getting me there for you
you're there for the before they're like
i said i'm not like the other guys and
then he goes but we don't want them like
we want you for you and i'm like say
that now right but when you see the
you know the belly no no that's what
they want and you don't really need to
doesn't it ah but this is the thing i
was watching old podcast the other night
but let me lose a lot of weight i have
lost some weight but at the same time
i'm far from perfect and body positivity
is only for women let's be honest wow
and i'm going to put this out there now
okay body positivity is a women only
thing
there's some reasons and i'm not blaming
women by any means
just in society
when when men put weight on and when
women put weight on it's a completely
different situation
i'm not saying women don't have things
that are unflattering to themselves and
that they don't like i'm sure they do
but a lot of women when they put weight
on
certain aspects of their body
get bigger such as the buttocks the
bombs such as the boobs or even some
people they're like
thighs in it right and a woman can pull
off gaining weight so much better than a
man because if a guy does people go oh
what's that why have you it's not the
same for men like we you know
right if we grow our breasts no one's
going for
you know well i mean and post-op and and
and thick hips on a man i it looks odd
i've got an hourglass figure at this
point but you don't keep that uh it's
it's it's a very large one for a man but
anyway
and i'm i'm just thinking i just need to
oversee these angles i'm worried about
these photos what i'm worried about here
is that the post shoot they go listen
bro we've picked out a selection of
shots here and you go look you don't
need to edit them send them to me i'll
put them on my iphone and edit them for
you that's my concern well you're going
to rob someone else i'm going to have to
pull up uh you know
ben when i say him because this is the
thing though in all in all seriousness
we had that interview a while ago
still not seeing enough chubby men on
that on that that is true and unfair
i'm right here yeah and i guess that's
why they're doing the photo shoot yeah
yeah right we better not one of them out
don't
genuinely though if you're going to
stand in a room and sort of model some
clothes i don't really feel like you've
ever done that before in a gym setting
but you are a good model i feel like you
don't know that but you've been i've
modeled i've had you be a model before
and i go brian you know
yeah i've got a distinctive look and and
hopefully we'll make some some good
photographs for that reason but
i just know there's going to be some
real bad terrible photos that i go if
this ever just can we just destroy this
right can we just smash the lab delete
it yeah because we just smash it off
yeah and they go it's on a car there's
loads of good there's loads of good ones
and i'll be like yeah but i don't want
the bad ones i've got to see the light
of day
i've already smashed it so can ask you a
question about body positivity then if
body positivity is about actually being
body positive and not just taking photos
from angles that make you feel good
about yourself why would you
like surely people should upload more of
the pictures that are bad of them if
that makes sense loads of women on
instagram i noticed i don't know many
men who do it but loads of women on
instagram go here's me sucking my
stomach in and here's me 20 minutes
later let's be honest like very few of
the women who do that and i do credit
them because it is important and i know
it does help a lot of men and women sure
some people do it for the right reasons
and some people do it because they're
like have a look in my body yeah like
body positivity when your entire
uh instagram is you half naked
that's not you being body positive just
to be clear
and i know people will attack me now
because they'll feel personally attacked
and they'll go
you can't tell us what body positivity
is but to me body positivity what is
what is the the true meaning behind it
is you're not doing it for yourself
you're doing it for the body image of of
women in general or men in general and
you're doing it to put a statement of we
all have these flaws we are this is
normal this is natural human and and and
when you do that it has to have impact
do you think
if every single picture on your profile
is you with all of your curves on shore
that is not for that reason it's because
you want the clicks you want the
attention and you want the comments and
and and by all means by the way i got no
problem with those but don't hide behind
body positivity is the excuse just say
in your caption dharma look good and and
embrace and be that you know do you
think that that's it i feel great about
myself i support that as well i just
don't like liars how many how many
people would go like so say that you
uploaded a picture maybe people expect
that from your personality i mean you
went down i look good people oh that's
his personality i don't think it is
though
anything i'm
i do have a copy side but if anything i
restrain that online because i know
people start hating you the minute you
have
uh
if you're an alpha male and you have
that bravado about you right people
don't like it there's there's certain
things that aren't extended to alpha
males one of them is pity right
like empathy and stuff like that like
when you've got the image of the big
strong guy
you can't really get like sympathy and
stuff like that you don't whereas
naturally we as humans we find it much
easier to look at a woman who
may not have self-confidence and stuff
and feel a bit i do i i don't feel sorry
for men the way i do for women i don't
know why it's just in my head and i'm
not saying everyone's like this but i
think society more so is like that so
for me
it's tricky on how to play the the game
of social media and all of that like do
i [__]
do i do do i say what's really on my
mind because that might turn a lot of
people off or
or guess what
if i go the other way
and i'm [__] over the top with it and
i'm like hey guys we need to be body
positive and not you know and people
will find that annoying because it'll be
[__] you know what i mean people
don't they don't want the extreme either
way probably but i also i'd rather know
i'd rather someone was honest rather
someone just said this is true and i
still sometimes i've got to admit i feel
that body positivity is still wrapped up
a little bit in the
the guise of hey here i am naked with a
full face of makeup and it's like
yeah or like hey here i am naked
but you know it's a great lighting
there's something that pisses me off and
that's and that's people using certain
things
that they're really not that attached to
to further themselves
so mental health is a classic one the
amount of people these days who bang on
about mental health as if they give a
[__] but really they couldn't give a
[__] just to be i'm a spokesperson or
whatever you know i mean and just saying
here but body positivity is is is a lot
like that like
so
i guess
in terms of
for men
there needs to be a lot more done and
and maybe maybe i'm the guy who laid
this this is step one
of in in 10 years time you might look
back and go god i can't believe that on
that day when i shot that you know i'd
have had so many pieces of surgery in
the decade following that but i've
thought about surgery if i'm being
honest with you because what kind uh
penis enlargement mm-hmm no i'm joking
um you get that done again what another
one yeah i've just just got the one now
so i'm gonna have another one popped on
there yeah uh for the [__] no um yeah
that would be handy though wouldn't it
jesus we read that story imagine that
some women would love that two penises
no doesn't shark have two penises well
we'll figure we'll find but this isn't
david attenborough right is it richard i
can never remember him no it's david
richard
yeah yeah yeah so did you ever think of
getting your nose done
what was wrong with my nose what was
wrong with your nose was what's wrong
with it nothing i did actually have a
nose job
did you so uh i was in a i was in a
fight
um and it was ever so slightly crooked
uh and i just had to have it reset
afterwards it wasn't like broken or out
like badly that is the nature of
resetting it but he had to break it
properly in order to set it and i always
like after i was like is that straight i
can but anyway
um do you honestly want to know i don't
really give a mine's not straight either
because i brought me either now so mine
isn't straight though not 100 but i feel
like doesn't say that to someone with a
crooked nose
so i broke my nose when i was a kid as
well and it was the day of the euro it
was euro 96 so i was eight at the time
broke my nose bam there i am in hospital
and the guy goes
yeah if you ever want surgery let us
know well this is what i was on about is
um obviously because i've lost weight my
stomach isn't as tight as what it once
was so i was thinking do i need to
get a a little suction
you know but like kim kardashian but
also that's my point is what the [__] is
a big man like like do you want his
question do you want to be able to walk
around topless do you walk around
topless
no i'm not that's not what i'm bothered
about it's more for myself you know what
i mean like sort of performance wise so
i'm obviously
not to bang on about the boxing again
but but the the lighter i am the better
i can perform as an athlete okay and if
i'm carrying around excess skin and it
don't get me wrong it's nowhere near as
bad as what i've seen some people but
it's just something that i'm bothered
about slightly you're not on a subway ad
or anything um because to me
surgery is something that
very vain people tend to get but now
it's becoming so normal and so that i'm
i don't know i'm it would be more for
like a practical thing you know what i
mean but then i looked into it i was
like [__] me
six weeks of uh
of recovery i mean i've obviously i've
got the show to do and stuff like that
and i love being active i love working
out and stuff so like it'd be me just
[__] sitting in bed a lot you know
what i'm doing the show around you doing
the kick off in the hospital bed with
rory on one side and me you know like
forrest gump where the mother's laying
in a bed and it'd be like use all around
me with mike's that would be so funny
that would actually be a could you get
this done because i feel like i want to
film that incredible i mean i mean you
could we could just do it anyway like
that next week do you do you think yeah
imagine like john lennon
in bed do you ever think that um
you know obviously because
you're older
and you lost the weight when you were
younger you were in very good shape so
you've had time when you've been in
shape and you know how that looks now
you're older you're a bit more of a with
your body you're all right with it so
you don't mind these sort of things so
much you know the older you get you the
more you sort of wear your scars or your
misgivings
no i'm i'm okay with it i'm i'm i'm
i'm not someone who's walking around all
day
you know what i mean like i'm you know
it's just a little bit of a belly not
not the end of the world but it's like
i was just thinking
it's not ideal and and i know that the
skin
it if i probably had it you know tummy
tuck or whatever they call it
i i would lose a lot of the weight that
i naturally i'd probably drop a [__]
stone immediately if not more how much
[__] skin is that jesus no but what i
mean is is like it weighs a lot you know
what i mean it's like yeah like skin
people's skin does weigh a lot like
generally so
if i'm 20 statement i'm 21 stone though
do you know what i mean and i'm getting
to a point where every little bit
matters i'm struggling to get past
barriers and i'm i'm not wanting you
like train stations and stuff no i'm
trying to get the lower twenty oh right
whenever i get towards 20
i've messed it up a little bit lately
you know what i mean so i'm not i'm not
being funny
you i've seen you messed it up a little
bit you know i've seen the meals
what happened without going on a another
uh oh brian saw depressed podcast
because we've done enough of those but
yeah it was it just
sometimes mentally i'll tell you what it
is half of it is like work overwhelms
you and then there's just not enough
time and before i know it like i've
missed breakfast and my blood sugar is
low and i'm like let me just grab a
burger a bit of a headache
and then um you know that 20-minute jog
that i was going to do is enough time
for because we got this to do that i do
the other do
and and yeah but now i'm back i'm back
on the horse how does it feel uh great
i'm training with laws a lot up up north
this some people who've watched the
knockout will know who i mean liz from
uh
yeah he's my mate from back home uh we
do boxing and uh i'd love to come up and
film you like i was gonna ask actually
boxing with him because i think it's a
very different kind of box into the box
you do in london
which is which is still like really good
training but it's more of um
it's more of conditioning i think you do
in london than you do like technical
aspects of people yeah i mean
you know back in west ham
it was a lot more of um the pain game
you know it was uh it was a hard workout
and it was sparring and it was a lot
more about the physicality of boxing and
it was great because i learned hey i can
take a punch i've got heart and i'll
keep going and i know what i'm made of
whereas you know when you've got one of
your oldest and dearest friends training
you
who you know thankfully is a
high-level boxer you know he's on the
tmjb with anthony joshua so you know
we're talking um you know he's number
one in in great britain in his weight
class he's all about technique and and
trying to improve me and look after me a
bit and uh
you know i've never been hit anywhere
near the same way really it's not the
same no and it's all about what he's
saying is look we're going to build you
up from scratch
like it's almost like a whole new thing
now it's like everything is like
footwork footwork footwork and
i'm i'm getting there uh obviously
you know i um i looked at tony bellew's
training footage the other day because i
interviewed him and i was like what the
[__] i'd love to be able to do some of
the things he can do and then i watch my
footage afterwards and i'm like oh [__]
do you appreciate more now watching like
a professional boxer oh it's given me a
whole different sort of thing i guess
it's like with you and watching a movie
director or whatever you because you
understand
uh what goes into it in the in the back
end you really get a different view of
it all right and you're almost so cause
yeah like similar to watching a film
like sometimes i'd be like how did they
do that with the camera the problem is a
lot of the time now it's basically they
did it in a computer cgi yeah cgi
basically um
whereas when it comes to boxing you're
watching it and sort of going where's
the where do these flies come from this
is just one or two flies on me so the
that you're watching and you're going
how is he doing that with his foot or
like that that hand is moving in a very
specific way the the most impressive
boxer in terms of after everything i've
um learned tyson fury just really the
sheer weight and size of the guy and how
he moves it's it's up this is the thing
is this this this look like pound for
pound list and people are like if they
were all the same size canelo it's not
the point though is it but this is the
this is the thing is like
for him to lose the level of weight he
did and to be able to move
like a [__] ballroom dancer at 19 and
a half stone or whatever yes he carries
it well but we might never see another
guy that size move like that in ever in
boxing it's it's so and and that's the
thing where for like as i'm training i'm
trying to get better at all the things
that he does really well near my biggest
weaknesses because i'm a big plodding
weightlifter i was anyway and that's
what we're trying to get me better at
and uh yeah like with derrick obviously
back in west ham it'll be very much a
beast thing and uh and grueling and keep
going keep going keep going whereas with
laws every five seconds the training
gets stopped then he goes that's wrong
that's wrong change that change up like
it's it's
much more focused on
just pulling me up on all of my mistakes
technicalities yeah yeah right i mean i
still get a [__] sweat on i'm so
knackered but um it's just different
attitudes and i think i'm glad i have
i've had both styles because
i think when i when i spar someone again
like my sparring now is going to be
worlds apart
i'm going to [__] people up now you know
what i mean sorry you were [__]
people like before so
not on camera i wasn't you've seen some
like little bits and that but now it's
going to be
i'm not going to [__] them up like a big
you know slugger i'm gonna take people
apart which is a very different kind of
boxing and quite demoralizing to be
that's one you know what's so weird
yesterday i was having the conversation
with um laws about you know the job and
and how how how he beats people
and that's the word we both agreed on
was like such a demoralizing way to lose
because before i'm just trying to land a
big hair maker
and yeah that's gonna [__] suck but
someone after a loss like that can like
kind of in their head they can go yeah
but i just got caught and he landed here
yeah
yeah we were fighting and he was bigger
and stronger therefore i lost okay
but when someone just takes you apart
technically and jabs your head off
repeatedly and you're just like
it is gonna
it's gonna surprise people that i'm a
lot quicker than what anyone would ever
expect me to be and i just need to get
there that that's why i'm frustrated
about my weight and my my like i'm
because
at my size and shape and not like you do
all the cardio you want but your body
kind of gets to a point where it's like
[__] me mate you're pushing like i i'm
i'm stretching after workouts for like
20 minutes
like just to make sure my body is not
because i'm training so much do you
think about doing like yoga or anything
like that i think yoga would be
fantastic if i could be asked to like
get the hours and the date to do it but
like stretching's all like going to
[__] get in we've got a list of
things to talk about um one of them like
the sex stories well maybe we should do
a problem or two at the end we might
actually do problems at this point my
laptop just for that purpose actually
one thing people have asked what to talk
about huh uh crypto and nfts i'm whale
i'm not in the crypto world i'm a whale
in the real world
yeah and that's the problem you want to
switch it tell me what you know about
crypto and nfts i'll tell you what most
people seem to know that youtubers keep
spending loads on them and bragging
about how much they have made of each
purchase
and
in my head i'm just like i've dipped my
toe in the water i've got involved a
little bit but for regular people and
obviously that's what i always think
about is like how
how how how is the real world going to
tackle this thing because
if you've got hundreds of thousands to
spend and you can buy
uh a picture of a monkey for a hundred
grand a space monkey or a cyberpunk and
we're all gonna buy these and everyone's
gonna trade them but we've all got the
cash
but then at that point yeah you make a
profit of fifty percent or whatever
right it's a lot more than that but but
regardless like yeah but
regular people a can't afford them can't
afford to take that kind of risk if they
can't afford to to even purchase one
who's got two ethereum just knocking
around but that's the point is like and
that's where when i sit on twitter and
youtube and i say at the like i've been
watching loads of there's this guy um
who's the one who keeps trying to take
everyone down coffeezilla oh coffeezilla
right okay he's cool like i watch some
of his videos quite quite not like
literally the guy's smart guy and i
remember watching it when the first
crypto thing kicked off and he exposed
some of the phase lads yeah um because
basically for those who don't know
there was this pump and dump which i'm
pretty sure most people know what that
is by now where youtubers advertise to
their audience how you get on on this
crypto and then
secretly they're selling it as as that's
all going down the profit is fantastic
because everyone buys in and they sell
and they they
dips yeah you scam your own audience
basically which is some of the phase
guys they're not phase guys anymore we
should say because the second that phase
found out about that they were straight
on out yeah um but i felt i know faze
banks was one of the biggest buyers of
this stuff and the biggest deal to me it
it feels like
kids with far too much money spunking it
on pictures of monkeys that other silly
rich people also want to buy off them
and and and my my experience of crypto
what i've got into so there was paddy
coin which we got involved with which
was a mental health uh coin which the
long term plan was to give free mental
health care to those who need it so i
was i was like right this is something i
can put my name to yeah that bombed so
fantastic but that's not that's very
different as well yeah to a pump and
dump no because you don't dump anything
no i've still got all the coins they're
worthless yeah but i actually held on to
them because worthless out of relatively
out of principle i was like you know
what it is i don't want to be
that like if anyone ever looks into this
i'm just going to make sure we've got
all the coins because everyone knows
this was genuine you know what i'm like
with mental health i would never do
anything that was underhanded or
certainly not used mental health to
[__] scam people so that was a bit
disappointing but
you know the the people who created it i
think they had a
a good idea but obviously
when the market crashes and you are
financially dependent on things going
well it can it can [__] can and i think
it's important that everyone is aware of
that and too often and this is part of
maybe where
the industry needs regulated and the
people advertising need regulate because
whenever we put out a gambling tweet we
we have to say responsible gambling and
all of that and realistically
these this crypto industry is not even
gambling it's so much more risky than
gambling it's you know with gambling you
get odds you know you really are and and
a lot of this is so
new right now that
you know
you just don't know what you're getting
into half the time and with me i dip my
toe into
two things uh after that i had um yummy
which was a coin
which was they that helped feed people
again another one me i was like oh this
could be good
you know what i mean like it and i was
like you know this could work the best
suckered you in bombed um
you didn't get that yummy yummy i i i
didn't it bombed and like i say
i was completely
aware of the consequences and i luckily
had the finances to accept those
consequences
um but obviously a lot of people aren't
and they're hoping to get rich quick
they're putting their savings into it
sometimes
and
it's it's a bad move now the the final
one which i'm still into and i'm still
hoping comes good
is uh vivi uh which is an aomi uh well
i'll explain it yeah basically vivi is
an app that basically people can buy
nfts on their iphone the reason why it's
different is it's got some of the
biggest brands
signed um james bond did it yeah so
they've got james bond um nfts um
spiderman right uh elliot you want to
shout anymore
there's rumors of pokemon and that was
part of the explosion of it because the
coin itself is called um omi or omi
economy or the company who makes it i
got involved with that because i was
like you know what is this these nfts
are a lot of them are total bollocks but
but there's some real substance to
batman nfts which they've got on there
like and and they've got um basically
you can have them in your room and all
of that [__] and they're working on how
you can you're really selling it yeah
but well yeah just ar is what you're
saying like i'm not trying to
you know it isn't really about that i'm
betting on the fact of
a lot of people like
stuff like pokemon you know i mean so
they they assign pokemon and as it
happens the licenser who works at the
company did used to work with pokemon he
was the one behind bringing pokemon to
america and calling it pokemon and all
of that but the thing is
i immediately took about a ninety
percent loss on that within
it within a few weeks now will you tweet
by the way from now on whatever you get
in on just so that i know not to get in
well interestingly it's now it's now
back at about 50 odd percent of what i
paid for it regardless i i bought in on
that for a long term potential payout
and even then i'm very accepting that
that could never happen it might never
happen but through through putting my
toe in the water right now
three attempts three misses basically
and it's important that the the regular
people also understand that that is part
of it you know what i mean and
um you also took three
fairly risky things fairly risky very
risks
whereas other people have kind of gotten
in on your ethereums and you know your
um obviously bitcoin there's bitcoin and
ethereum and everything else is
basically old coins and uh some have got
more potential than others like for
example ecommerce i think is in like the
top 300 yeah already and it is still you
know the vv app is still a bait up it's
it's not alpha um that's where they get
you involved
and uh but but yeah i i think
when i see youtubers
sort of saying oh you know you need to
get involved in this you need to get
involved in this i get their excitement
they're making so much money regular
people can't necessarily do that and
also aren't in a position to take the
hit on the risks and and i know that
youtubers don't always think like
responsible adult too
they're whipped up in the moment and
they're loving this new craze but also
but it is
it's serious business and and kind of
add to that without regulation and
that's kind of the point of
cryptocurrency is you know you can't it
was made to not really be regulated so
it's difficult then to bring in
regulation well i know everyone's got
this story but i'm no different and
years ago
uh a guy who used to buy stuff on silk
road
uh which for those who don't know was a
place where you could get pretty much
anything yeah that could get hits done
on people i mean yeah you get a lot of
drugs and all of the rest of it and hits
and and bitcoin was the currency and he
was telling me me you've got to get in
on this there's a load of murder
i got no
so it was no use to me telling me that
anyway but
uh looking back at it you'll be a
millionaire now yeah but [__] it i'll
get a millionaire anywhere someday yeah
someday soon and but we don't know if
it's going to be off a comey
the point is that
a lot of the people who the cr the
influencers those kind of guys who got
involved with it they probably didn't
know they were screwing anyone over
they're probably in a house of people or
a group of mates who are like we're
gonna do this thing do you want to get
involved all you got to do is sell it to
your audience blah blah blah this guy's
20 or whatever and he's like yeah cool
i'll sell out to my audience i'll make a
load of cash and they're like yeah and
he'll make and all the audience will
make a load of cash as well and before
you know it there's probably a young
influencer who's selling a load of
crypto and doesn't realize they're
screwing someone else out of something
in his bedroom i'm not saying i'm not
saying that's everyone but i'm saying i
think some people
aren't they don't look at the terms and
conditions they just go i'm gonna make
money i'll do it those lower level guys
who did get caught out by this coffee
zilla guy um
yeah it's just sick in it like he didn't
catch him he caught them in the act he
literally caught he literally this
[__] he literally traced uh what
they've been tweeting they looked at the
transactions
going on online and basically narrowed
down wallets that would have been theirs
it was it was pretty genius it's some
sherlock [__] that he is i like
sometimes the other aspect is i i think
this is the first generation of this
stuff so
this is like you know when we first have
money i think we'll look back in this
like you know when you find a roman coin
you go to a museum there's like a roman
coin in the museum and you go so old it
looks so [__] in like a hundred years
they're going to be going that's a euro
that's a well they're going to be like
that that's an oh me or whatever you
want to call it or like that's a bitcoin
i can't believe that this is what they
did back then because it will be so
evolved there's some like 12 year olds
sitting in their room right now learning
to code who's probably going to be by
the time they're 18 a [__] genius and
they're going to code the next facebook
or the next instagram but for bitcoin or
for you know ethereum or
do their own part of the problem is that
the boom has been missed by a lot of
people and a lot of people are i i get
that it's still in its infancy
technically yeah but everyone has worked
out that this is exploding so now new
coins are popping up left right and
center and there's there's just almost
too many
in my in it for someone like me to
decipher between
what's what's good what's not good and
there's so many different youtubers who
claim to be experts in this stuff and
you get hit with a wave of coins a wave
of youtubers claiming to be in the next
guru and i'm at a point now where i'm
kind of like you know what
i'm just going to sit and watch this
that's the smart thing from the
sidelines because right i i'm not in a
position
and uh like a lot of youtubers where i
can invest crazy amounts of money and
take and take losses potentially we've
had to pay for a producer now uh yeah
that's why we've got subjects yeah today
um but
also um
i need to focus on what my bread and
butter is which is this stuff you know
what i mean and i think if you're if
you're fortunate enough that you've got
[__] you money and don't have to upload
four or five videos a week like we do
then good on you you know what i mean
doc aro and play the game
but that in that and i don't think
i just think i want to keep my eye on
what what is my thing you know that's
kind of it as i think and this is
definitely after lockdown and after
everyone being in a house for a while
you know we've we've all picked up an
instrument or a like a skill or whatever
it is and a lot of people sort of dip
their toes in about 100 different things
because they were locked in a flat or a
house and they were just like yeah i'm a
i'm a trader now yeah and it's like well
you sort of you did a one online course
from instagram you're not a trader
you're just a person well actually
that's why and i'm i'm not just this
isn't like a ironic plug but free trade
actually feel
and this is just us talking openly yeah
this isn't sponsored or branded or
anything but when when i started
learning from the guys at free trade i
was like this feels safer do you know
what i mean like i feel like i can get a
lot more information about everything
i'm getting involved in the companies
that can get like they're reputable
companies and you know what i mean like
they're real brands that they're real
they're selling real things you know so
i have got so much more context for
whether this is risky or not it isn't
just a picture of a monkey with no known
creator
for you for not knowing how valuable the
monkey is
buy as many monkeys as you like that's
what i'll say
do you know do you know when people get
out of context
buy as many monkeys as you like so
strange i um actually know
the guy whose girlfriend i know a guy
and he has a girlfriend
go for it unusual wow um mostly your
mates are just single lonely losers yeah
like me yes um
yes so
he his girlfriend
is the person who keeps all the art for
damien hirst who's damien hirschman a
famous artist yeah famous artist and
he's the one who got into the crypto
thing right yeah
he did this smart thing which i thought
was pretty genius
he sold one nft version of the art and
one real version of the art to the same
person and i think you could buy them
for about two and a half grand at the
time something like that
it's a good well spent two and a half
grand by the way if you got in on that
congratulations
in a year's time you can choose to
either destroy the nft so delete it it's
never going it's never going to come
back or burn the art
and in one year
it basically makes it more valuable
because you've gotten rid of one of
those two things now after people bought
the two and a half grand nft and the art
it instantly went up anyway so it's like
laundering money in a way
but i thought that was kind of genius
now i was like okay i can understand why
that is a valuable thing i can't quite
understand why
a monkey wearing a cap is a is a
valuable thing but i can understand why
a real world artist who has like kind of
a cultural
gravitas if you like like damien hurst
would be important and i'd love to
interview a true expert on this sort of
stuff who is a true expert that's the
problem everyone claims to be and there
are mostly bullshitters when whenever
you're in an industry where everyone
claims to be an expert
95 are [__] welcome to youtube so
um
we're all experts here mate we're all
experts here yeah you want to upload on
a friday because actually well no don't
know don't upload it on a friday this is
uploaded on thursdays
i'm sure that there's people screaming
at the at their phones or whatever there
are saying you don't get it right you
don't and i accept i do not i do not get
it but i can't help and think that the
billionaire who bought logan's monkey
off him for however many hundred grand
one day is going to be looking at this
monkey going well that's [__]
worthless now isn't it
but at the same time
like i'm saying about the the the vivi
app i i get why that would be valuable
because the story behind spider-man and
batman and the the
[__] decades upon spirits of history
that make those nft specials legacy
elliot bought the [__] delorean from
back to the future it was in the [__]
flat with a door lifting up on that yeah
i remember at the time thinking
what a [__]
loser but the point is it's now worth
how much money elliot 60 grand
it's three times okay so a virtual car
that any [__] could write ellie
doesn't even get the good one no there's
a life-size one but anyway a lifestyle
yeah but anyway the point i mean the
point is like this reminds me a lot like
pogs back in the day do you remember
pogs can i just say i made some notes i
actually put in the note pogs
so weirdly we must be we
so the the art on pogs back in the day
pogs were these things where you had a
slumber you put your pog down again
you've said a slammer and sort of just
held it up there so that you need to lay
the basis for the whole game what you've
done is you've used a technical term and
then explained another technical term so
you know when elliot explains the nfts
and everything and he goes you just
gotta log in through the back wallet
going through your pancakes welcome
shove it up your ass and you go oh
fantastic all right okay so pogs pogs
were a little cardboard sort of circular
um you know little art there were tiny
little coins made of cardboard that you
would stack up and the idea was you and
your friend would stack up
your collections together right and then
you had a heavier coin that you would
throw at them uh and you were basically
if you you put one pog down you're made
to put one pog down and then the slammer
gets slammed off of them and if you flip
both over you get to keep the pogs yes
and it was a fun game far more fun than
anything i've seen done with nfts by the
way you've not seen the delorean's uh
back doors open so i mean on a phone i
have right she's a lovely woman also you
could just watch the video of that
happening on youtube exactly on on back
with the future yeah exactly i will get
back to that in a second though because
i think i understand that but but
regardless look
it reminds me of that and ultimately
eventually you realize you've got bags
and bags full of pogs and you're now 16.
you know what i mean and the pogs are
worthless you can't wank over the pogs
and
and anyway so
there is a hint of that way i think
where is this going because
like i say
batman etc i see the value
mr the monkey guy i don't know i i guess
the the thing that is added to that and
what you're saying about the legacy of
batman those kind of things
if you can own a monkey
by the way it's a rendered digital
monkey that they then are quite like
they've at apparently there's like
little functions on the app well this is
the sleeping that's making the punch
this is the silliness about it monkey
you you post a picture of the monkey and
you're like hey guys i just bought this
for 100 grand or whatever
and then someone could literally save
that picture to their phone right and
they've got the same thing right it may
not have version one or whatever
but yeah that they own the monkey but i
i get it and look i'm not complaining
about that because i get collecting is
fun and i understand why you'd want to
collect the lord of certain like i have
that in me as well that sort of need to
have you ever collected anything uh well
i premier league sticker books premier
league stickers
i remember the best one was 1997 that
sort of peaked merlin yeah
and i also loved like collecting action
figures when i was a kid what kind of
action figures are we talking about
just turtles uh toy story
uh all of the all of the best ones
you've mixed all the different universes
together people thought marvel was
genius brian was the first genius he had
woody from toy story fighting donatello
and then robin coming in on a bike turns
out robin's gay yeah did you know that
they've rewrote it and robin's now gay i
get a lot of messages i get a lot of
messages really yeah cause a lot of
people obviously think it's a sick diss
to say i'm the robin to your batman it's
a good one i think you make a great
robin just to be clear but i think i can
play a very comfortable very well just
to be clear
we i'd be being and you'd be joker
though yeah absolutely we've worked this
one out we've worked this out we've been
very intricate
if you haven't um been watching youtube
long we're the bad guys yeah on youtube
and we're definitely not the ones
pretending to be the good guys just to
be absolutely clear yeah we're the
[__]
because i love being ben yeah and i love
being the joker they expect one of us in
the wreckage brother right elliot you're
gonna have to die with the plane the
point is with the with that i don't want
a [__] monkey that's been owned by
some billionaire in
beijing i don't care about that but the
idea is
no it's nothing to do with him the
monkey is not chinese all right what i
want to be absolutely clear about it's
secondhand beijing
it's the second hat and that's what i
would call it but the point is i don't
want beijing monkey i want uh some
famous guys monkey because he's owned
the monkey oh so this one so this is why
logan can charge a fortune and that's
why these guys make it like their
twitter avatar and those kind of things
because if you make that image famous or
that becomes like a socially relevant
image it's almost good that more people
copy and paste it and put it on their
phone background and do that sort of
thing because then people go i own like
a bit of a social movement here right
like pokemon cards obviously have always
been valuable but logan particularly
blew the [__] out of that and made it
way more valuable and you know if you
were holding on to pokemon cards pre
pray logan's live streams
you love him now you're like you've just
made me millions just by bringing this
back that's partly what i've also
learned from the whole cryptocurrency
thing is people kind of want to sell for
a million they buy for a thousand they
want to you know they want to
sell it at a million i'm one of those
people right some people go i buy a
thousand i can sell at five thousand i
five times my money i'm extremely
grateful for that right
so
not everything is a get-rich-quick
scheme it's sort of like a make a little
bit of money and uh and and that's where
i would recommend people go down the
mall
stream certain road right um and i'm not
calling anything certain no but i said
more certainly right because anything
right now is more certain than the
crypto industry and nfts in my opinion
and that's what i'm saying about um the
free trade situation what we learned
what
it's not me pushing free trade
specifically here it's what i what we
learned in their offices about investing
in proper companies rather than you know
this sort of thing but we learned it can
get your offices which are very nice and
um look i love the fact that there are
people out there especially young people
making a [__] fortune of pictures of
monkeys good luck get your money if you
can do it but
realistically i've got to step back and
go i don't [__] trust this right now
and it seems like a very volatile
situation and i have been on the
receiving end of that volatility
numerous times already in every time
i've touched down that was a lot of
shots in the dark that you took i did
and this is the thing i could do because
i'm fortunate but i think it's important
to to tell the other side of the story
on this podcast because
a lot of people like to celebrate their
wins very big but not many people will
own their losses especially not like me
right for me once shame on me for me
twice shame on you i bought crypto three
times shame on everyone but this is the
thing i'm quite happy with the vu thing
because it does it it's showing steady
progress right to me
i would take that over the insanity that
i say out there right now do you know
what i'm encouraged by with the whole
bitcoin crypto thing it's becoming more
mainstream so uh i think you can trade
it on paypal now there are more and more
celebrities that are getting involved
with it in the states so there's like
tom brady is advertising one i think his
friend
that's another thing when when that's a
good thing for us is it though yeah
because dads and idiots who watch nfl on
the weekend i'm not saying anyone anyone
who watches nfl is an idiot because i
very much appreciate that but what i
mean is anyone any idiot who's just
watching the tv on the weekend goes
oh cr i'll put some money in that
good for us
again i'm not trying to push vive
because like i say i'm
i'm sort of relaxed about this whole
thing like it could go wrong what i've
accepted it you know what i mean but
they i think they've got the license for
the nfl if i'm not mistaken do they yeah
so can i get a rare tom brady on vive
well
they haven't released them they haven't
gone there yet because they're they're
absent beta but i imagine down the road
that'll be the when the alpha's come
along yeah that's me that'll be you i've
been doing a little bit of nba trading
on nba top shop i made anybody no idea
how and why it works still uh i'm not
saying it's a money laundering app
but
there are a few times where i go
that layup from this obscure player who
plays for the denver nuggets has just
sold for fifteen thousand dollars i
don't understand this and i don't know
why that
particular thing is to solve fifteen
thousand dollars but it seems that that
transaction of money has gone from there
to there
why would that happen
and i no one can track it no one knows
why like it just seems like someone's
just pretty much used a platform to
illegally move money between two and i'm
not saying nba topshop did that so i
quite enjoy it but
it's a it's a bit like the old fifa
thing
where you could basically make anything
any price you wanted which is how people
managed to transfer fifa coins around to
different
um players
on the game why do you think the sidemen
are so rich well actually it is down to
fifa coins and ironically
um
i wonder where this is going in football
terms you know what i mean because
yeah the premier league days of
collecting stickers were huge so no
doubt someone
is sitting on that and thinking we're
going to make a fortune off premier
league nfts is that sarah
sarrer
sorero
there's a football one there is one that
does it but these guys i had to
unsubscribe from the email in the end
sent me about 50 emails a day going rare
neymar uh one of two out there buy it
now for 10 grand what you're saying
elliott
oh
bitcoin's now an official currency of el
salvador as well so that's encouraging
for anyone who lives in [__] el
salvador or is ever planning on going to
el salvador uh my
my passion for travel
uh is temporarily dead because i'm not
traveling awesome dude you've been
traveling oh i went on holiday let's
talk about your holiday sure why not
yeah uh so just to put some context on
it you went back to the country where
my wife was a refugee from during the
the um i'll call it genocide because it
was um during the the genocide which
country would have been kosovo which is
an internationally recognized country by
some people there are some countries
that don't recognize it for political
reasons oh really i don't upset anyone
here do they say it's not a country
because they're still class at ours uh
because uh they
so everyone knows there's a conflict in
that area at the time and uh serbia
believes that land belongs to serbia and
albanians and kosovans believe that that
land belongs to
um
albanians and kosovans and so there's
kind of cosmos uh well kosovo is kind of
they're
it's like me saying you're geordi but
you're english okay so
kosovan people are very much linked to
albania if that makes sense okay because
they are albanian but they want their
own country to be able to be
self-governing and sovereign and i get
that and that's important done your
research i've had to at this point i'm
pretty sure you've passed the exam uh
well i have passed the exam we've got a
child so uh he's a great kid easy way to
pass the exam yeah exactly which all
exams are that you see we've got ears at
school i'd have skunked it oh
so we decided uh post pandemic that it
was important to take our son back to
kosovo because he needs to learn about
his history he needs to learn about his
history while he's young enough to
absorb it all exactly well he's well
he's under a year old
i love the fact that he's just making
notes like bloody hell this is amazing
i've got to admit i do you know they say
like travel broadens the mind
i think when you're young and you are
like you're a sponge for absolutely
everything
when we went to kosovo i remember
thinking it's really hot first of all
i'll talk more about this when we're
going around he was observing everything
and like taking it all in when he came
back i don't i don't know if it's real
or maybe i'm just looking at him and
going yeah he's changed i felt like he
looked different because horizons yeah
he went yeah there is a bigger world out
there yeah
london's a big place
i love london but i want to travel as
soon as i'm old enough genuinely i'd
love it if he did that i think it'd be
incredible well if he's like he's old
man he's going to enjoy the look of
foreign women and that'll lead him off
to all corners of the club he's a
good-looking little kid of course i will
say
by the way for those who are wondering
he looks a lot like lawrence like
a lot but with like little touches so
he's got like um thicker lips than i do
and those i don't want to piss anyone
off when i say that i know you're not
pissing anything oh you're caveating it
well no no no but
it it's a carbon copy it's it's lawrence
with blonde so i sent my dad a picture
of him the other day and dad said when
was this picture taken of you yeah i was
like no no there's a picture and he
actually looks so much like your dad as
well by the way so my dad came to visit
yesterday and we went into a car he kind
of looks more like your dad even than
you almost does that make sense chubby
cheeks will do that yeah yeah once the
puppy
what about that but the point is
like they both have quite sort of like
you know the mckenna's have quite um
sizeable cheeks should we say and
soaring nuts for the winter
clearly all three of us like stood in a
row in a coffee shop and the guy went
are you related and we were like yeah
well done sherlock mckenna boys yeah it
was a nice moment so anyway we fly to
kosovo um i've got a little bit i get
like a nice offer so we fly business oh
yeah i felt pretty good about that i
felt like you know post pandemic i
deserve a nice plane ride i think you do
on it because i i don't know anyone who
loves travelling more than you do and
you know i know it really bummed you out
not being able to do that so we booked i
booked that as a surprise so when we get
to the airport i'm like
we're not going in that line we're going
in listen i bet you should loved it she
loved it because you and i have flown
business before and that was the first
time i ever flew business we flew
business when we went for a business
meeting somewhere else right yeah and we
kind
re i realize now we kind of spunked it
by playing mario tennis for the full um
that wasn't true business though was it
it was like half business half this
coach yeah it was just normal yeah but
to me
what so what we had there should be the
bare minimum that everyone has right and
and that was a good argument but for
some reason planes don't believe that
people deserve that no and that's why i
hate flying and i truly hate flying like
i feel like hell for me i'll just be in
one long plane right right where i'm
like
just cooked in like sardines yeah back
in the day when i used to um i used to
fly to london back when you know we
first started doing this because it's
not insane to you that they made you fly
to london like is that any nobody in the
train no one made me fly but like it was
it was just like oh we'll fly because
it's quicker in theory but like in
theory
i don't want to make this a complaining
podcast but it is the fafsa i [__]
hate airports and i [__] hate
aeroplanes what's new castle airport
like i've never been there well it's
like any airport they're all [__] to me
i hate every airport you go i'm about to
tell the story about how much i love the
airport
well like obviously i love flying anyway
i love airports i love going places so
we i mean it's just loads of cues mate
what could you possibly like about
airports tell me
everyone's everyone's queuing everyone's
rushing around everyone's not no one's
polite everyone's oh we've got to get
the bags up what what is what is fun
about that the business lounge
was what was fun about that it's just
the lounge was sitting in windows and
we're in a lounge right now technically
yeah but i'm not waiting to go anywhere
and there's not a woman who constantly
comes over and goes can i get you
another top up for that or can i get you
another sandwich
you know there's something about lauren
it's like
all the years i've picked up about you
is like you are obsessed with like
the finer like side of life like that
especially if it's like travel no but
there's a word and and to me there's a
word that sums you up wanker no
it's it's that
luxury luxury
but when i say
before i met you i was like luxury you
know but you go
luxury no but say it the way you always
say luxury you really see it it's good
luxury and i hadn't felt like this in a
while i i i accept that so we're all
sitting in this lounge and obviously flu
sitting there like wow this is good do
you know what i mean my man did good
exactly i'm proud of that we're sitting
next to all these older cars well done
thank you well i did feel proud of me
you're a boss i did also think in that
moment i was like should i text brian
and go thanks for the money and go you
know no but it was like a moment i was a
bit like this is cool and even even our
son is sitting there going this is good
he's a little pimp he's sitting here
enjoying his second refill of milk or
whatever his third refill of milk with
coco melon on the side there so we're
all sitting there like having a good
time
constantly just bringing me is he
breastfeeding not anymore no yeah sorry
i was just mentally
picturing because you yeah you've seen
my wife um and so
so uh we then we get on the plane he
falls asleep oh this but like
pretty perfect and i was like what if he
the thing is you know when you take off
he just kept doing this
like that
and i was like yeah i know so you give
him a bit of milk oh yeah
yeah so that you're right when he's
sucking on the bottle
yeah yeah
i did that yeah um it helps his ears
yeah yeah so then he falls asleep on the
straight away we have him we have him
laying down in a seat in between the two
of us along come like our meals honestly
it was the best flight i've ever had and
then we get to kosovo i genuinely was
worried about that because in my head
i'm like this is gonna be a [__]
night babies on planes yeah yeah some of
the other babies they're like
yeah and you turn around and go will you
shut that kid up yeah your baby's [__]
i'm sorry can you draw those curtains
that go back to coach please my baby
brilliant yours is rubbish she did cry a
little bit when we were taking off and
at that point i remember thinking [__]
i paid for i paid for business class but
like on a discount some other people
here will have paid for it and i'm in
there with a kid screaming in their
faces
suck at nerds yeah basically yeah i was
a bit like deal with you yeah i mean
let's be real though if you're going on
on a holiday in summer and you don't
expect children on a plane you're a
[__] mom yeah exactly like don't
don't complain about that yeah it's
summer if
you know if you want to make sure
there's no kids on the plane charter
your own party well there was one woman
who sat down in business and uh she was
sort of opposite and a little bit
forward and i was sat in the aisle with
him sort of on my lap and she sat down
opposite and as she she went
and i was like
i'm sorry i didn't realize this was your
plane like genuinely if you've got a
problem with it don't travel with the
public if you have a problem with it i'd
literally just i'd be straight up going
what what what
but you know me i'm the opposite of that
i'll go your card's marked see you in
five years when i'll get revenge um
that's the point so you're a real slow
player i want yeah like you don't want
to feel the knife going in you they
don't even know the knife is going it's
like batman ironically you're more like
poison ivy right it's the slow blade
yeah you don't say come in and the twist
of the knife i slowly twist and before
you know it um i i've had some leading
out on the floor good flights yeah nah
there's been a few noticeable ones where
i've been throwing up after night out on
a plane
i remember that night we ended up in a
uh sorry i ended up in a strip club and
um i didn't end up in it just be
absolutely no i wasn't lost yeah i
remember going back the next day and i
was just hurling up on the plane and
everyone's like there was guys like
taking videos of me who recognized me
and that and i was like were you sorry
you were throwing up in the public space
in the plane but i had three chairs to
myself because they're lola to be fair i
will give credit on in in some regards
is
some of the staff on board the planes
god knows how much [__] they put up with
they let you out of the cage and sort of
run for no but they were like um
there were cute little ladies sort of
fussing over us and they're like oh
we'll look after you oh that's nice you
probably fancied me just as the sick was
dripping off my bottom lip off your
beard because it went down the beard i
swear to god the most unattractive thing
ever is a beard after someone's thrown
off with sickness oh god i love it
welcome back to the podcast subscribers
by the way uh yeah i i i i [__] hate
fine so so what was the country like
though
when you got there uh because because
obviously
without going too too hard
or every little detail
you know your uh your missus family had
to escape a lot you know they went it
wasn't a great situation it was a
terrible situation in this country and
it's a situation be nice for yeah like
where where one day um people are living
side by side and like um so you know
serbs and cross serbs and albanians and
gospels are all living side by side and
the next day because of the government
and those kind of things because of
political situations you're not quite
sure who you can trust
there are police going around just
inviting young men to go to buildings
slitting their throat shooting them in
the back of their head all these kind of
things
and that's what's kind of bizarre when
you're there is how
that was still so recent in their
history oh yeah so you know with us the
world war ii and world war one feels a
little bit wrong it feels hundreds of
years away right actually but you know
your granddad was brave and you know
your great uncle was brave and all these
kind of things so you've sort of got an
element of pride about it because you're
like yeah this person died for a good
reason like you know you know i think
about that now mm-hmm those poor [__]
they'd be turning in their graves if
they've seen the [__] show that this
country's become but anyway carry on
more about that later so uh we were
there and then there are people we're
walking down the street in her hometown
and they're like oh yeah this is where
50 people were shot
should we get an espresso and i'm sort
of like wait there were 50 people shot
over there like that's terrible
and
the whole country is quite small anyway
what are the people like
you know how there's a every country
seems to have a vibe so like for example
english people are sort of too polite
and quite subservient right uh americans
are seen as you know arrogant and a bit
loud noise what
you know i'm generalizing but i'm trying
to get a gauge for what it was like over
there it's quite sort of um i call them
humble people um and quite sort of uh
welcoming extremely welcoming extremely
proud like they'd always want to tell
you something they try their best to
speak english because obviously i'm not
speaking that much great albanian and
not that much not that much i'm learning
i'm trying to learn trying to write that
um because at least once you get angry
with you you can understand i know so
that is part of it i've started to
understand people's curse words and
stuff like that so i'm literally like i
know what you're saying now you know
that right yeah and you so we're walking
around this country's like 38 degrees
for the first three days that we're
there what was the boy like
he was fine actually if anything it made
him sleep longer he was like yeah this
is good i'll nap in this but we don't
get to nap i have to push this kid
around in his in his push chair for
hours
the food
was a lot different to england
he said diplomatically there's a lot
more meat there's a lot more rice would
i have like because i do like meat and
rice right you would actually quite like
meat and rice yeah and but i wasn't i
don't think what kind of meat is it just
anything and everything mostly beef
because it's a
mostly muslim country so there's no
there's not any pork really so you
couldn't get bang as a mushroom you
could you just get pork uh you get a
beef sausages but like there are
delicacies which are pretty good like uh
we went to one of their local like
here's the thing everyone there is
running their own business this isn't
like you know in london it's like you i
work for pret or i work for blah blah
blah when we go to this town the guy who
works in the kebab shop owns the kebab
shop the guy who works in the taxi owns
the taxi everyone owns their own [__]
i mean that's fantastic and honestly
that's kind of the way this country was
before margaret thatcher
privatized or yeah privatized everything
uh nationalism yeah and and i i think
people take a lot more pride in their
work right in that regard and i would
imagine that because i've been to a
restaurant before where the guy like i
don't know why i'm but it was a great
restaurant i once went to he earned it
and and a guy owned it and he almost
welcomed me in as if it was his home
right and and when people have that
attitude i don't know i just feel like
it's a it's a level up from when
and and you know i
think um the pride that people have it's
a shame more people don't get that in
this country and now
it and i think it's a very deliberate
thing that's been taking place in the uk
for many decades now but yeah go on
sorry what i was going to say was it
kind of gave me a new perspective
because
obviously i'm around my wife and her
family like quite a lot and they're very
proud to be from this part of the world
as i would also say there are probably a
lot of serbian people out there who are
also on the other side of what turned
into a conflict
who feel very proud about whether we're
not going to get loads of political uh
messages i get enough i like honestly i
know a lot of lovely serbian people i'm
good friends with uh people like voodoo
and people like that they're lovely
people i get a lot of hate uh from just
random people going how how can you
you know have a wife who's albanian you
disgusting blah blah blah i want to come
kill your kid those kind of things and
like that's a fair i know i know um
without going into all the details i
know recently there was a lot a lot of
that sort of uh stuff after you became
yeah you know yeah that can i just say
one thing about that that all popped off
the first day of our holiday and
obviously i didn't see it coming because
there was no sort of there's no warning
for this sort of stuff happening on
youtube well so i didn't see any of that
coming and so
flu and i are trying to enjoy our first
ever holiday as a family with a baby
with a baby and
a lovely romantic time hopefully where
you guys are going to finally have a
break after you know kovaden
let's be honest a lot of stress and i'm
and you're no different than anyone else
in that regard but i think when you
spend a lot of money to try and make
something special happen right as a
youtuber the last thing you want is to
open your phone up and have people
saying what about your kid your son your
son's going to watch this in 15 years
and be ashamed of you
or messing flume and being like
uh yeah why would you marry this prick
blah blah blah flew gives as good as she
gets and i will give her that i i i i
yeah
which is quite funny she's a face
literally she's she's yeah she's
extremely feisty if anything i think
people are lucky she's not on camera
yeah exactly yeah yeah to be honest that
was part of it like she was uh
how soon at the holiday like day one
okay so we land
day one this hit
and so i'm sort of you're getting lots
of people slagging you off online and
all of that and in my mind at the time
when i first saw it i thought well this
won't be as big as it became
so it became much bigger than i thought
so originally when i saw it i went oh
tweet about that and that will pass that
i mean without
i couldn't honestly i'm sort of over
there
and i am sort of over youtube drama
genuinely because i think it's something
that you do when like we have content to
make you know what i mean i'm actually
trying to make content again football
and fighting and all that and i could
give a [__] about this but i am more
interested in how you are feeling yeah
because
you're my best mate i love it a bit and
i care about you and your family and i
wanted you to have a great time and that
was one of the things in my head when
you were out there was i could give a
[__] about youtube drama
uh because it's yet to dear god tomorrow
fish and chip newspaper but
i know that this is so important to you
and that's what i was feeling and yeah
and
and that was part of it and i guess i
was sitting there also feeling like
i was a long i felt in a very unusual
scenario that i'd never really been in
before at home and then i was also in a
very unusual scenario in another country
where i'd never really been to a country
like this before which is extremely hot
extremely out of my own comfort zone
kind of and i like to travel but i've
never really traveled to a place where
there are power cuts in the middle of
the day sometimes because someone's
decided to turn the power off because
there's not enough power within the
country we're talking about a country
here that's become its own country very
recently so there's a lot of like
logistics things that happen that people
just sort of accept so when the power
goes off for them they're like oh the
power's gone off but i'm sort of like
in my mind during the whole day i'm
going power's gone off that's six hours
for all these notifications to rack up
so the power comes back on my signal
comes back on on my phone and my phone
just goes
do you remember the um the first charity
that we did it was like that the sidemen
charity match where we slagged everybody
off
absolutely everybody
we didn't get invited back for the
second award but no you know guess what
we got back for the third one slugged
everybody absolutely and you know with a
funny thing about that i'm starting to
see there's a pattern that when i slag
something off i don't get invited back
for the second one yeah so i'm i'm
noticing that i'm gonna have to do our
own character
honestly i'd love to raise more money
for charity because i'm such a selfless
person i'm so giving but i just don't
get enough chance to show people that
so and so i'll say can i just carry out
the whole conversation by saying there
were some things i felt really bad about
and i felt and in that moment i did some
reflection and obviously i'm sitting in
another country doing some reflection
and going you know what and maybe i made
someone feel terrible and i don't feel
good about that yeah but that's not a
good state to be in while you're on
holiday and no one's saying you feel
sorry for me i'm not going my whole
whole day was ruined all i'm saying was
i'm describing the situation i was in
and you might be able to relate to it so
i'm sitting there reflecting probably
not for most people because it is a very
weird thing yeah and i can say from my
own experience which is is obviously
huge to a degree
um very formative when you're
feeling out of control
of of a certain situation
um
it's it's a horrible feeling when i'm
sure many people have felt in in
different ways whether or not you're
getting targeted um
by
maybe there's a neighbor you're in a
dispute with or if you know people when
you when you feel targeted by a large
group of people and and when it comes in
a way of like that it's very hard to
sort of know how to handle it and there
is no manual for this and then you also
have
more importantly
the the
the child to look after in a foreign
country where yes obviously you know
your his family are there and stuff like
that but still you're you're on guard
you wanna
you don't quite feel as safe as when
you're at home yeah so there's a lot of
different things going through your mind
i can only imagine and when you're at
home you can go to your own bed
and also when there's a lot of youtube
drama
a lot of people on youtube who have
drama don't actually have families
they're people who have very little else
going on in their lives so they can
afford to take five days out and go i'm
gonna be
feeling a bit down or anxious or
whatever five days there's no one else
relying on me and they're probably
making a lot of money off adsense or
whatever it is so they can afford to
take some time out right
i felt like i'd ruined our first family
holiday myself because in that moment
because she was getting affected by it
she was affected by it she was affected
by how i was on the holiday because i
was obviously um you know not like
myself but also there were moments where
we were also incredibly grateful and it
goes the opposite way where it swings
the opposite way and you're like [__]
this like this is a great day i'm really
enjoying seeing this meeting you meeting
your extended family i'm glad that you
enjoyed it and i really am like glad
that you were able to just put that to
one side because i know how much it
meant to you and you really and despite
what anyone says i know you're a good
person despite your sense of humor being
warped and dark and [__] up just like
mine uh you know you you really do
deserve that holiday and you you know
and
to work so hard to try and give your kid
a lovely experience like that to show
them where he's a family we're from you
know that that says a lot and i'll
preempt two things people in the
comments saying things like um oh you're
just trying to make people feel sorry
for you in a situation where you were a
wanker or whatever i get that right and
people can be wankers oh no you you've
you've acknowledged that yeah we've all
been wankers at some point in our lives
online but that's not an excuse but all
you did was you all you can do is
apologize which you've done right and
and try and move on but you know you
know me and what there's two things that
always get me into trouble i say things
thinking that on the other end there is
someone who's receiving that
understanding what my intent is and so
the the thing i then hate i i think hate
it more than anything else is not being
understood
and that people don't understand where
you're coming from so the want for the
whole of that time for me to just go
no you don't get it that's not what i'm
doing the problem is laws some people
don't want to understand you know what i
mean and it's a it's a deliberate thing
where they know fine well you know what
you're like and who you are and all of
that and and i'm not taking shots here
it's just there were so many people who
were talking online and all of that i
was just like
what lawrence mckenna are we really
are we going to do this are we do you do
you remember him roasting the sidemen do
you remember the charity magic
do you remember any of this you know you
don't have comedian in your twitter bio
but you're a piss-taking you know jokey
not serious kind of guy but that's my
that's a demeanor that i've
adopted online and some reason
a lot of people in that moment thought
that's all that's 100 years
the reason for that is is because when
we talk our audience who have a long
long-standing you know um relationship
watching us and and absorbing our
personalities
we don't need to say at the start well
we're going to make some jokes now you
know can i just say the irony was the
day before the whole thing broke and
before we went before we i went away on
a holiday you and i actually had quite a
frank chat on the phone yeah and i said
to you um actually
part of my problem is i don't think i
may be able to mentally
process
um i'm able but i don't think i have
mentally processed what it's like to
have this platform because i still think
of this as your platform that i just
happen to be on and i'm like the the
mate who's tagged along if that makes
sense and i said to you i don't feel
famous i don't feel like i'm better than
anyone else i don't know it was so funny
i think we spoke after it all broke
because you were like i don't feel like
anyone it was sort of
not feeling acknowledgement or or that
sort of
uh self-worth that you were wrestling
with yeah and after this happened i
remember laughing with you going well
you wanted uh you wanted people to know
you are i was trying what i was
wrestling with was like the idea of um
giving you credit and knowing what my
part was in that and not taking away
from you and knowing where you end and i
begin but also that we're a team but
also how to tell other people that
without going um actually i sort of did
quite a bit of this stuff as well and
not making because you know what last
night before when we said we were going
to do the podcast again i went back and
i'll watch some old podcasts
and i was i'll be honest that was about
five glasses of champagne deep at this
point after we noticed in the group chat
right
and um
uh and
my the effect alcohol alcohol has on me
is it makes me become like a bit out of
body so i start to sort of observe
myself and i'll watch myself in videos
and be like
[__] like well look at that guy
and it made me look at you and um go
[__] he was really good in these
interviews and was i patronizing brian
or was i thinking i was better than i
was or was i giving myself a bigger role
in this podcast mentally than i've ever
had and so i i've really that's that's
been my whole past six seven months is
questioning like my whole role on those
things and where i'm going and that kind
of stuff so when all this came up not
only was it obviously a painful uh thing
to approach [__] maybe i was a bit of a
[__] but that was midway through my own
set of reflections about me and my own
changes in life and becoming a dad and
those kind of things so it was a big um
it had quite a big
impact but what i would say is it's i've
made we've made that into a positive
impact and it's been a really reflective
like positive time i think if you don't
wrestle with
your behavior
and
regret you're not a man you know like
okay to me one of the and i buy man i
mean a growing
adult yeah i think the hardest thing
about being an adult is uh
learning to live with regrets and i have
i've had a few but then again
to few dimensions
no seriously i've had a lot yeah um you
know this is the thing is we we get into
a serious subject and then we make jokes
right it seems to be a format i i one of
the hardest bits of my life is regrets
and all of the things that i i look back
on and think oh could i have done that
could i have said that differently
and ultimately
i have to go into my heart and question
that and go yeah but where was where was
your heart at in that were you being
were you being selfish or
or in your
genuine logic did you really think that
this was you know and
and i've and i have been selfish at
times and i have been a bad person at
times and i have done things that i'm
not proud of but also
generally speaking i know i've got a
good heart and i know i care about
people and and when and when you were
going through you know um
it was a storm in a tea cup it was it
was silly to me it was like yeah a bit
of an [__] but [__] me like but i
realized like
a lot of that was down to the perception
that people have of you that enabled
them to sort of get super aggressive
with it and and ironically two wrongs
don't make a right you know
if one person's a [__]
and then everyone then piles on that
person for being a [__] and goes
completely overboard about it they're
also [__] do you know what i mean so so
um and that's not to diminish
the point i'm making is is is it
a valid point at the start is
yeah bad joke [__] what whatever
hold hold your hands up it's over and
done with but the
the way
social media is and the frenzy you know
it reminds me of the simpsons when they
all got the stakes and the flames it's
silly and and they those this huge group
of people don't realize like
you're going overboard now like you know
and and i get it i get it because in the
heat of the moment when you feel
attacked you want to attack back right
and and
ultimately we all have to grow up we all
have to be more mature on lane and
that's the thing i think i've really got
out of this year is like
just let it go right like if i ever have
a real problem with someone i ain't
going to talk about it online i'll just
punch them square in the face you know
what i mean okay that's a real problem
and and yeah and to to to sort of add to
that that was what i was wrestling with
uh whilst i was away on holiday
and it was this idea of the one minute
you swing from so one minute you swing
from
this is all so silly um and your mind is
going through
even if you know you've got enough you
know it's silly but then when you say
the thousands of tweets and thousands of
messages where other people are taking
it so seriously
you in your head are going oh my god
this isn't silly this is really serious
and the shame yeah is very real
shame is a killer you know shame shame
is why people commit suicide yeah it's
the number it the minute anyone makes
someone feel
that deep dark shame
that um
the girl who presented love island um
sorry caroline caroline flack that shame
that she felt for what she was being
hammered for and all of that
like that's the thing that gets people
to go over the edge then and ultimately
we've had more than enough time online
to realize that there's a healthy
balance to be had between criticism and
annihilating someone for a mistake and
the mistake the punishment has to fit
the crime is what i'm trying to say here
right and and i'm not even having a go
at the people who had to go at you no
what i'm saying is
we'll just need to learn and i think
literally one of the first things i said
on the call and it was a support call
because you guys were sitting at home
going [__] laurence is halfway around
the world we don't know how he's
reacting yeah we wanted to have a bit of
a catch-up right and i think i tweeted
something which was probably a mistake
because it you know that and i'm i i
said i've said
point blank period to you i said this is
a result of a lot of your other [__]
this is a lot of people who are man
united fans man city fans who've been
annoyed at you the avatars
is this is people's chance to go ah we
get to get the guy who who's very funny
and gets other people or whatever but
the point is and this is what i was
trying to get at before is
you've got to question your intent and
what's in your heart and and and where
you're really coming from in that moment
usually unless it's a joke which we do
make a lot of them i'm trying to come
from a genuine place and and i know you
do as well and i think that's what i
wanted to hold on to is
you know i did say look mate you've been
a [__] in the past and you brought this
on yourself yeah and i was very honest
with you yeah yeah totally um but also i
said you're a great person and
let's be real how many jewels on youtube
have landed that's the test of time like
the reason we have is because we
genuinely love each other we we look
after each other and we look after
everyone around us as well by the way
and those people look after us
absolutely we're a [__] family here
so so it was just important to go yeah
you've been a [__] but you're not
actually a bad person right remember
that you know and i think
what i what i wanted to do was give you
the real [__] yeah i mean and that was
really helpful and not not the lopsided
we all hate you but also not [__]
you and say oh you're great and you've
done anything wrong i think also it
helps to have a friend who's been
through an uh
something probably ten times hundred
times worse than what i've been through
but having been through
uh the process that you go through when
people are trying to make you feel
ashamed and what's strange and what i
can understand why people like caroline
fleck did what she did
not because i at any point had suicidal
thoughts or got anywhere near that
because i didn't you're saying your
experience was minute but even still you
get a window right and i got this
interesting window into uh hey you've
criticized a mental health charity event
kill yourself
now there's an interesting irony
delicious irony in that that i
definitely took some pleasure in but
i
from the proportion of people who
messaged me and went
you're you should end your life like
you're the worst person online
it came in like a slew and i didn't feel
bad because of that
but i i did see the impact that it had
because flu had never seen stuff like
that and flu had never gotten messages
from people saying your husband should
kill himself and i hope he dies or
saying things like i hope your son dies
of a serious illness
or things like that i remember you
telling me about that as it happened so
just just because i don't want anyone
thinking he's exaggerating or whatever
like this is just a it's just life for
us like and and um
i understand
when you sign up to this game there's a
lot of benefits there's some drawbacks
and and and
me and you've signed up for that but
your kid hasn't you know what i mean and
then yeah and i think there should be a
line
and i guess um you know when when we
cross the line um the people think that
that's a fair game then but the point is
is you don't get to keep the moral high
ground when you come down and go further
down than i did and that's and and you
can get [__] at that point you know
what i'm saying and that was and but the
the temptation to then say to those
people get [__] and you know like that
is very tempting to like just tweet out
just get [__] or whatever or you're
you know like we enjoy creative videos i
enjoy comedians flu said to me like
let's watch some of your favorite
comedians let's watch them dave
chappelle there's a dave chappelle uh
stand up and in no way am i contrasting
myself to the legend and the living god
that is dave chappelle he starts his
show and he goes
one thing you've got to remember
i'm saying some things because they're
funny but sometimes the funniest thing
to say is mean
flu turned to me and she was like we
don't need to watch anymore sure
generally i watched that um that that
guy who i've really liked the australian
guy yeah yeah and he was he was
literally making um
like i i around that time i was watching
this and he goes uh
out of everyone i'd want to be raped by
bill cosby because at least he gives you
drugs first you know and the point is
and that's a horrific thing to say
afterwards everyone's laughing but then
they're like oh and he goes hey just
because i said it doesn't mean i really
believe it right you know and and the
point is is
you know our jokes and we're just
for context we were watching a live
stream of the charity event having a
poking some phone making some silly
jokes and
not thought through not on the level of
not on the watertight level of a dave
chappelle or jim jefferies or any of
them and and hell it was just killing
time having a laugh and and really
actually trying to endorse what the
charity you know and just in the in in a
just sort of something to do really more
than anything and clearly that was
understood
by some people and clearly
you know if we thought about things more
deeply you'd have never have said some
of the things that you've said and you
would have thought about how you want to
word it and how to make the joke better
and more respectful and and all of that
but the point is is this is where it
comes down to knowing who's saying it
and that's what i'm talking about is
that's the context that's the important
thing and i am grateful for a lot of the
people who reached out to you a lot of
the youtubers who were messaging you
supporting you and saying look we're not
surprised by this and we know like who
you are we know you're a good guy
and just forget about it it'll be over
in a minute anyway but what i'll say is
um there are there are a few people like
um tom and callum who went about and
made the event i felt really bad and i
feel like i approached that situation
and apologizing to them and trying to
make it right in the wrong way did you
say situation there as a dig no no no
yeah yeah you know that's the kind of
joker i am i'll do it in i'll say that
this is the new way yeah exactly just
going to call it
you won't see it coming um but clash of
creators we were all for it and and i
think the multiple times that we said
you should donate and stuff like that so
right
i think
out of context we're lost we made a
video about ps morgan where we destroyed
them but yeah like certain people
you know are asking for it and and you
you know that they're playing by the
same rules
piers morgan playing by the same rules
there's been times where we've clipped
people up
and replied the things they've said like
joe joella but back in the day he did a
music video that i took the piss out of
and he rang me up and genuinely he was
he was like upset about it and i felt
[__] terrible because in my head and
this is not trying to be funny i thought
he knew it was [__] right right
right and i and
and and sometimes things that are
obvious to me
like the production standards of that
charity event and having a little giggle
about it
not realizing
that people have put their hard work
into that stream and probably not and
not being sensitive enough to that
um
you know i apologize personally i know
you're apologizing and like i say i've
done this to my own mates before by
accident and that's why i give joe well
all the credit in the world for having
the balls to ring me up and telling me
right bro you've hurt my feelings you
[__] up and you shouldn't have done
that in the fullness of time like i'm
sure everything will
will even out and i'm you know i'm sorry
to people like callum and tom who put a
lot of effort into that event and you
know i i actually do the problem for me
is here if if something goes wrong
you'll either be really mad about it and
and be like [__] sake but the
likelihood is while you're having your
[__] sake that camera wasn't right or
whatever it is i'm sitting at the side
probably in that chair over there
laughing going brian's really taking
this seriously i think i'm gonna make a
joke about this right now and i'll make
a joke to you and it might lighten your
mood or you might go yeah you're right
like we [__] this thing up or you and
i have [__] up things on shows before
and afterwards we've gone and laughed
about the fact that we did something
wrong and
what i didn't realize was that's us i
did realize this but like it was our
sense of humor and this is our space and
sometimes as a joker or someone who
makes jokes you can have some fun can
make the wrong sacrificially if you if
you watch every live stream we've done
in terms of the sporting events don't
you i mean unfortunately yeah they're
out there the ksi versus joe weller live
stream i was so drunk during that event
the audio was terrible i look back at it
it looked like a pile of [__] that show
but
you know [__] it it was fun it was a
laugh it was a time and i think we were
taking the piss the whole time i was
[__] you know i think it's important
to just sort of
don't take yourself too seriously
secondly i don't know if the way that i
see myself is how a lot of other people
see me and that's what i found that's
what i found it's never by the way never
nobody does but that's what i found in
that time most bubble bursting was that
i was on this incredible holiday with
the like the love of my life and our
child her family and we're exploring a
place which is going to be incredibly
important to him in his life and at the
same time i'm completely breaking down
in my mind
what what it is that i am and who i am
do you know something funny
weirdly probably one of the best things
that will ever happen to you yes right
because i've seen so many youtubers
ditch their identity of who they really
are in favor of becoming someone else to
be more liked by the rest of the
community
the worst prison that you can be in is
the one of which worrying about people
what people think about you
and when you get told so many times
you're a [__] you're a waste of space
all that it weirdly
strips away that element of shame and
all that because you start realizing
i'm just not though
everyone was like personally yeah and i
yeah you i made a mistake you made a
mistake whatever like i think once you
go through that scenario it toughens you
up it it it
it does humble you and and some people
need humbling and let's be real here me
and you have needed [__] humbling and
i am
not too proud to admit that right can i
also say it's also part of the act oh no
no like
hear what i'm saying yeah
we make ironic jokes to
you know and act very cocky and arrogant
to get people laughing because that's
funny but sometimes i am being cocky
yeah and i will admit that and sometimes
i do think i'm the best [__]
podcaster going and all of that right
but equally sometimes
i hate myself right sometimes behind
closed doors i
think
you know why didn't i do this better why
haven't i achieved this yet why am i not
a better friend a better person about
this about that and i cr and and
unfortunately
one of the one of the things that makes
people funny and i'm not saying we're
world-class comedians but having
having made millions left
having an
having an eagle eye to be able to
pinpoint
flows in other people which you can then
make jokes about
often when you look in the mirror that
eagle eye is is there tenfold because
you know every conversation you have
with yourself you know every floor you
know every mistake
and you're even harder on yourself which
is why people like robin williams you
know have a secret depression
behind the scenes but yet can say the
funniest thing in the room that no one
else can say but he's you know
and it's a unique perspective to have it
is and and i look we're not on that
level but we do have some ability to do
that and clearly otherwise we wouldn't
be successful at this point i i want to
let you have your final say on actually
there's anything else you want to say
about it because i know
it's it's over and done with and
obviously we're going to sort of
you know
some people are going to talk about this
now and yeah and it carries it on a
little bit a little bit but we don't
care like an aftershock i think that's
the thing that personally anyway i don't
give a [__] you know i don't give a [__]
about
um what people are going to say after
this because if you know what's in our
hearts and you you know the context of
who we are you get this and you get what
we've said so far is fairly sensible and
and and
self-critical but also
balanced you know what i mean is there
anything else you want to say here i
guess from what i've i've learned a lot
in that time maybe also about my own
criticism of other people online
i think one thing that is going to be a
very difficult thing to achieve and it's
definitely definitely difficult on
twitter instagram any of these places
is to
be able to have a conversation where you
can try and see where the other person
is coming from and learn what their
intent is rather than learning oh that
person screwed this person over there
for that person is a terrible person and
reducing people down to
just these binary things you're a good
or you're a bad person go kill yourself
you know you're a great person this
person is a genius this person's an
absolute idiot i think that's a very um
simple and a deliberately simple way of
looking of course you know what i mean
and some people will but we are bad guys
lawrence just to be clear and you know
what there's something delicious about
being the best oh no i love it yeah i
love it i always root for the bad guy
that's why scarface is my guy yeah
having said that you know in in films
where a nuclear bomb is about to go off
brian's not sitting there going come on
in die hard you weren't watching well
a little bit in die hard i wanted alan
was amazing yeah that was it yeah oh god
yeah that was amazing that was that was
in english actor playing an austrian yes
doing an impression of an american
that was talent yeah that tell him he's
not a comedian or whatever he's not a
comedian very much uh yeah very well
rickman's still alive he's dead god
bless him god bless um
one of my favorite actors yeah we have
been talking a while i think i should
wrap this up now it's been a nice one i
get that it's a nice comeback pod we've
got loads of guests lined up we are
going to be making this more regularly
the main thing i want to finish on is
i have never given less of a [__] than
what i do right now good so
enjoy the ride [__]
[Music]
you